good evening and welcome to this virtual
meeting of the council
first may i remind all of you of some
domestic arrangements
please ensure that microphones are muted
when you are not speaking
that you do not interrupt the speakers
members are reminded not to use the
messaging
messaging or chat function during the
meeting unless it is to report pecuniary
non-pecuniary interest or to notify the
chair that you wish to make a proposal
that if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting
you may be asked to leave additionally
you'll be invited to speak
and ask questions by the chair please
await your turn
if members lose connection to the
meeting that they must contact the
member support officer mandy smith as
soon as possible
as this is a virtual meeting you will
not need to stand to address the chair
members we are using a new electronic
voting system this evening
and subject to the urgent motion on
notice being approved
the voting will be recorded on the
website
i'd like to remind everyone present that
this meeting will be broadcast
live to the internet and will be capable
of repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential or
exempt
items if you make representation to the
meeting you'll be deemed by the council
to have consented to being filmed
by entering this meeting you're also
consenting to being filmed by the
council
and to the possible use of those images
and sound recordings for webcasting
and or training purposes the council
members
of of the public the council members of
the public
and the press may record film photograph
or broadcast this meeting
when the public and the press are not
lawfully excluded
can i move to the agenda please
and we're looking for the apologies for
absence
thank you chair we have received
apologies from councillor ebern and
councillor phillips
we are waiting for councillor amaroson
and councillor pratt
to um sign in are they present please
okay okay it's julie noted and i'm sure
um
all councillors and staff wish
councillor e burn the very best in a
recovery
uh moving on declaration of interest by
councillors
are there any declarations of interest
no good we're now moving to the urgent
motion
on notice i refer you to the urgent
motion
on notice that was circulated on tuesday
i'd like to vary the order of business
and take this item before item three
on the agenda councillor morley would
you like to move the motion please
thank you chair
this administration has consistently
pursued the use of technology
to provide the public and press with an
enhanced level of access and engagement
in our meetings
this approach has been crucial during
the cov19 pandemic
where we have maintained open
accountable and transparent democracy
by fully embracing virtual meetings
indeed baba
and mid-southwark district councils were
the first councils in suffolk to hold
fully
virtual meetings open to the public
an extension to our use of technology in
virtual meetings
is the adoption of e-voting to replace
the lengthy and cumbersome process of
roll-call voting temporary alterations
to the constitution to allow e-voting
have already been made by the monitoring
officer under delegation
however i firmly believe e-voting is the
way forward for a robust and efficient
means of voting for all our meetings
with a virtual or in person
hence i am proposing that the council
adopts e-voting as its primary means of
voting
i've also listened to the concerns
raised by other councillors about
losing the current enhanced level of
public access to voting
afforded by the process of roll call
voting
this is essentially the ability of the
public to see how each counselor votes
on every item
something which we didn't even have in
face-to-face meetings
unless the public physically being
present in the meeting room
therefore this urgent motion also
proposes a constitutional change
to enable the publication of a record of
voting at
every meeting on the council sorry
on the council's website to ensure the
highest level of openness and
transparency
this will not negate the process for
formally requesting a recorded vote for
the purposes of the minutes
or the statutory requirement to formally
record
the budget vote
so the motion is that this council
permanently adopts
e-voting as its primary method of voting
in all meetings
and that a record of all votes cast at
meetings of the full council cabinet and
committees
be published on the council's website
with immediate effect
further that the monitoring officer
being authorized to make the required
amendments to the council's
constitution now before i propose this
um i would also like to thank councillor
stringer for his support for this motion
because unknown to me both he and i were
discussing
this same motion albeit with different
people so i'm grateful to councillor
stringer's
support on this so thank you chair
i'm very happy to propose this motion
and i would call for a second thank you
casa molly thank you and do you have a
second to please
[Applause]
uh yes chair i'll have it a second um
but if i may i reserve my uh right to
speak
council richardson that's noted and yes
you can thank you
okay we're now going to move to the
debate councillors
will only be allowed to speak once for
three minutes
and this will be timed please use the
hands up
system to indicate that you wish to
speak
councillor passmore please thank you
very much chairman i
don't want to speak for long because i
think it's a very very good idea i shall
certainly be supporting the motion
and for those who might have been
anxious about public access i think
the fact that the the the uh who votes
and how they vote
will be recorded and uh be there for
posterity for
many many years to come no doubt i think
um does deal with that and of course in
the past
as uh the the leader says if people were
there they would have seen it
how to vote the only other occasion of
course when people would know how
individual councillors voted would have
been if there'd been a recorded vote
but i think this is an excellent idea
and it certainly has my full support
thank you very much
thank you councillor field
thank you it certainly has my support um
i've been familiar with recorded votes
in this way
to county council for many years
and find it acceptable to many extent it
enhances democracy to be able to see how
councillors have voted
i have a few concerns perhaps around the
edges about the
possible pressure that could be bought
on some
councillors but perhaps that's a risk we
all take in
in volunteering for this role so
i just summarized that really i'm in
support and i'm sure i can uh
pledge the support of the uh green and
liberal democrat group to this motion
council field thank you and some very
good points there so councillor stringer
please
uh thank you chair um when it when all
of us uh become elected as we
as we have uh you're basically
exercising
power on on others behalfs
that power may have got diminished over
the years
or unchanged and altered but i always
think it's a it's a it's a basic
courtesy that if you're exercising power
on behalf of someone else
you should at least tell them what
you've done and this is a way of openly
demonstrating exactly what you've done
thank you chair i'll be supporting this
motion
thank you so very important points there
uh council richton you reserved the
right to speak do you wish to say
anything
uh yes thank you chair i will be brief i
just wanted to echo what councilman
moore has already said that i think this
is a really important step forward
to enhancing um the democracy that we
exercise as a district council but i
think it's also demonstrated
um this you know the virtual meetings
we've had it has proved to be a little
bit unwieldy at times with
the sort of a constant role called
voting so i think this is a step forward
to making our
deliberations a lot more efficient and
as i think other councils have said it's
it's already been done
um at suffolk county council for quite
some time without without any major
hiccups so i think it's absolutely right
that we should be adopting this so i'm
very happy to second inspection thank
you very much
thank you i could see no other hands
apart from uh councillor stringer is
that
just you forgot to take it down thank
you legacy
thank you very much um okay counselor
molly do you wish to add anything
no i i think the merchant says it all
and i'd like to thank everybody in the
chamber
hopefully for your anticipated support
thank you
thank you i'll now ask the corporate
manager governance and civic office to
conduct the electronic vote
and again using the mod dot system
thank you chair councillors could you
please open the vote in the modern.gov
app by clicking the plus sign in the top
right hand of the agenda screen
and select selecting attendance and
voting
in the voting tab the vote for this
agenda item will show in blue
please click on that blue line to open
your vote thank you
can you indicate councillor fleming can
you indicate how you wish to vote
for please and councillor otton
four thank you
that is unanimously full thank you
thank you and therefore that is carried
and thank you for trying your best with
that this is technology but the backup
will always be
the fact that you can use the the voice
so we practiced it we practice it when
it's going wrong and
and it seems to work so that's good news
okay um i'm now going to move on then
to mc2010 to confirm the minutes of the
annual meeting held on the 24th
september 2020 for accuracy only
are there any issues with accuracy
could ever propose to please
chairman i just like to propose adoption
of the minutes thank you
councillor penang and a second to please
i'm happy to second thank you chair
council miller thank you for seconding
and ask the corporate manager governance
and civic office to contact
conduct the electronic vote okay thank
you chair
councillors again can you open the vote
in the modern.gov app by clicking the
plus sign in the top right hand
of the agenda screen and selecting
attendance and voting
in the voting tab the vote for this
agenda item will show in blue
please click on the thin blue line to
open the vote
thank you
and it's a unanimous vote again for
thank you
thank you the minutes of the meeting
have been confirmed and we've signed at
the next
practical opportunity um mc20-11
chairman's announcements
i refer to the paper mc2011 for noting
thank you i would also like to take this
opportunity to advise members
that as i am unfortunately unable to
present councillor haddingham
with their past chairman's badge
personally i've requested it be sent to
here as soon as possible
and i know this isn't the norm but we
are in unprecedented times and i do
apologize
to not doing this in person because it
is an important event and an important
badge to go for
moving on then to the leaders
announcements i would like to invite
councilor morley to present
her update please thank you
um just a few things to share with you
today
um well not sharing with you because you
most of you will have heard of him
already um cisco cifco acquisitions
sifko has purchased three further
properties in this month
totaling almost ten and a half million
pounds to bring in future income for
councils to invest back into local
communities
there are two these are two neighboring
warehouse buildings on cosgrove way
in newton for 2.475 million
in addition to an office building in
epsom for
7.97 million the industrial units are
both led to building supplies company
woolsey uk limited
the office building is home to epsom and
helia university hospital
nhs trust on a long term lease
this ensures low risk returns for the
councils at a time when kovid 19
is significantly affecting other
traditional income streams
kravid 19 support grants so this scheme
has been expanded
and the additional restrictions grant is
open to businesses
who were trading up to and including 4th
of november
who were instructed to close because of
the national lockdown
or can demonstrate that they have been
significantly financially impacted
by the national coronavirus restriction
measures the funding available through
the grant will range from
1 34 to 300 000
sorry not three hundred thousand three
thousand
in line with the local restriction
support grants
applications for the first round of
additional restriction grant funding
must be submitted by friday the 18th of
december
19 tears when national lockdown finishes
central government has just placed
suffolk
in tier 2 local restrictions from the
2nd of december
the main reasons cited for this are
suffolk's current
coveted infection rates local hot spots
and the pressure on hospitals and while
suffolk has so far seen comparatively
lower levels of
infection than elsewhere in the region
and the country
the current infection rate of 85 cases
per 100
000 people is more than double what it
was when suffolk first entered tier 1 on
the 14th of october
at the beginning of september there were
just five cases per 100 000 people
there are 116 covic patients in suffolk
hospital beds
as at the 23rd of november
and although mid-suffolk numbers are
fewer than the suffolk average
we still need to stick with it suffolk
because the virus is no respecter of
boundaries
as stuart keyboard said every one of us
needs to keep following the rules to
stop the spread of kobe 19.
we need to ensure our hospitals can
continue to care for people who urgently
need help
including those who don't have covet
we need to be responsible today for a
better tomorrow
thank you chair that's the end of my
update
thank you councillor morley any
questions for the leader please i'll see
councilman matthewson please followed by
councillor field
thank you yes in view of the um
announcement by government yesterday
regarding the
use of public works loan board funds
will you be seeking to borrow the the
remaining 30 million that's been
authorized by the two councils
thank you councillor matheson we are of
course considering all aspects of the
chance for spending review announcements
yesterday
including to the changes to the public
works loan board and the consequences
for cifco
thank you thank you thank you uh council
field your hands gone down now i believe
uh
do you still have a question or not
uh it was really an extension of
councillor
matheson's question i i was going to ask
that uh
um under current circumstances
many companies in commercial business
are
unfortunately severely challenged and
going through administration procedures
and doing that they
they tend to insist on lowered rents
and wondered whether this has been taken
into account in your decision making on
citco uh
i'll ask our assistant director to
answer that question if i may thank you
yeah yes please emily are you available
i'm happy to support um yes absolutely
clearly um
the the covert crisis is having a
significant impact upon
rental market uh in both uh particularly
in the in
business sector and so i would
anticipate that that's something cifico
would look very carefully at before
uh looking to purchase any further
properties clearly they have
clipper amateurs both in terms of
geography but also in terms of yield
uh that's critical in terms of how cifco
operates so
yes absolutely the rental return is a is
a
key determinant of any such decision
making thank you
thank you thank you are there any other
questions
thank you thank you councilor morley
okay uh moving on then we'll now
go to receive notification and petitions
in accordance with the council procedure
rules
corporate management for governance and
civic office will report on petitions
received
chain please thank you chair and please
be advised that we have received the
following validated petitions
a petition for immediate climate action
in suffolk district council with 62
valid signatures
and a petition regarding the condition
of the vicente site in branford
with 135 valid signatures both
petitions have been dealt with through
the usual petitions process
thank you thank you and to all
counsellors
copies of the responses will be
circulated to you in due course
questions by the public in accordance
with the council procedurals are there
any
non-received chair thank you we do have
questions by councillors in accordance
with the council procedure rules
and i refer you to the questions by
councillors in the table
papers councillor
matheson to councillor whitehead please
thank you chair yes um so
councillor whitehead thank you for the
um
the reply which was appreciated that i
had an opportunity to read it for for an
hour two beforehand
and um it's encouraging to know that you
are studying
the issue of our investments and our
climate policies
and um i noted particularly the um
the the new service from arlington close
advising about that and it would be good
if that
input could go to the audit and
standards committee sometime
soon so my supplementary question
is regarding in paragraph four where you
speak about the
the oil majors are in the forefront of
this evolution
towards low carbon um that
isn't the evidence that we have at the
moment
that the the oil majors have actually
done quite a lot to delay
at the shift of the the world's economy
to low carbon
and and they're still investing far more
in prospecting
and um extracting fossil fuels
than they are in renewables
unfortunately and
finally the question did you know that
the the oil major
uh exxon has just dropped out of the
um the top 500 um share index in the
states
and um and one of the companies that
that's coming into it is the electric
car company tesla
and i just wondered whether our advisors
are actually
quite recognizing all of that
the council white said to respond please
yes thank you
um i i only just recently got the news
about the aisle in close development so
but i
agree that should be uh more widely seen
by the
joint ordinance standards um in terms of
the
oil majors i think the reality is that
these companies are just so vast i think
shell itself is 100 billion pounds
very difficult concept almost to get
your head round so
and the amount of money that they do
invest year on year
is quite phenomenal um but so
even some movements into renewables
although the figures themselves you know
are quite large i suppose as a
percentage of their total investments
uh is small but ever increasing but
um i mean i think bp themselves are
working very closely
in either denmark or germany to look at
using offshore electricity to generate
enough power to produce a great deal of
hydrogen
in terms of the new developments for
hydrogen as a fuel for example and
um the well reality is i said in my
written response
these companies need to either reinvent
themselves or or they will
disappear and they have that
determination need and
um both in financial magazines and so
so much to the sort of sunday newspapers
etc i've seen so many articles over this
last
i guess 18 months in terms of the sort
of work
that these majors major oil companies
are doing
i wasn't aware that it was excellent
that dropped out of um
the dow i i did i didn't know that tesla
had joined and
it is quite phenomenal to think that the
market capitalization of tesla is
actually larger than
ford you know you know a company that's
still making so many
cars you know worldwide and tesla is a
new developer
uh you know the new entrant in the field
again as i said in my
uh response to you that an investment
portfolio in 2014 will certainly look
very different to today's
and i can have every confidence that our
uh professional managers
you know are running those portfolios in
a
in a good way thank you yes thank you
it's notable that our
pensions are coming out of fossil fuels
and i hope we'll soon be following them
with the rest of our money thank you
thank you and thank you for the response
uh moving on now i'd like to
invite councillor williams the chair of
the overview and scrutiny committee
to introduce paper mc20 stroke 12 which
is for noting
councillor welland please thank you
chairman yes
um we've had two overview and scrutiny
meetings
during september and both were joint
meetings with baber overview of scrutiny
the joint committee considered options
for the future delivery of the
public realm service members received an
excellent presentation from the
assistant director for environment
and commercial partnerships she covered
the existing method of delivery in the
two districts
the in-house service in mid-suffolk and
via a contractor in baber
the presentation covered four options
for future delivery
it was agreed unanimously to recommend
to cabinet
that the future model be an in-house
service delivered to both districts
the joint committee then reviewed the
housing delivery test action plans for
each of the two districts
we carried out our annual review of the
joint homes and housing strategy
and the homelessness reduction and rough
sleeping strategy
the committee thanked officers for their
work especially
at the start of the covid restrictions
and their innovative approach
to delivery of the housing service the
committee considered
a confidential report on future
arrangements for disabled facility
grants
and made a recommendation to the two
cabinets
my report is for noting and i'm happy to
answer any questions
thank you councilwell do you have any
questions for council welding please
no thank you thank you councillor
william i'd like to invite councillor
guthrie who's the chair of the licensing
committee to introduce paper
mc20 stroke one three and move the
recommendation and report councillor
guthrie please
thank you very much chair licensing act
2003 statement of licensee policy
statutory five-year revision the five
yearly review of the statement of
licensing policy for mid-south district
council has been carried out
it is for full council to decide whether
to adopt the revised policies
a public consultation was carried out
between 20th of august 20
and 16th of september 20 in respect of
the statement of licensing of policy for
mid-suffolk district council
the policies for mid-suffolk and baber
are broadly the same
apart from details relating to the
nature of each district
since november 2005 the local licensing
authorities have been responsible for
functions under the licensing act
2003 section 5 of the licensing act 2003
requires that each licensing authority
shall determine
and publish a local statement of
licensing policy
relating to the discharge of its
licensing functions under the act
the licensing team revisited the
statement which has been in effect since
january 2016.
the report before you seeks the approval
by full council
of the revised policy statement for
mid-suffolk so that it may be adopted
for publication
and ready to take effect from the 7th of
january
2021
the licensing team has undertaken the
necessary work within the existing
resources and fee structure
the legislation aims to secure full cost
recovery of administering licensing act
2003 functions
through fees payable for license
applications and ongoing maintenance
the fee banding system and fee levels
are currently set by central government
by regulation as they have been
unchanged since 2005.
the previous government decided in early
2015
not to activate the provisions of the
policy of the police reform and social
responsibility act
2011 section 121
which would have devolved fee setting to
local licensing authorities
the current draft will be the fifth
edition of the council's
statement of licensing policy under the
licensing act 2003
the licensing team has the necessary
experience
stakeholder contacts and networking in
place to ensure that a wide balanced
consultation has taken place
the consultation took place over a
period of four weeks through various
channels and
media no responses to the consultation
in mid-suffolk were received
the lack of responses is not a concern
to the licensing team
as well as all its existing premises and
club license holders
150 relevant businesses and all
licensees totaling over 500
work and organizations were consulted
including the parish councils
the statement of licensing policy is
based on licensing act 2003
and the statutory guidance section 182
of the guidance
which limits the degree to which it can
be amended
there have been for been four previous
reviews and consultations
and the policies have been updated and
refined on each occasion
it is therefore reasonable to assume
that the consultees
are satisfied with the content
the draft statement of licensing policy
for mid-suffolk
was considered by the mid-suffolk
licensing and regulatory committee
on the 2nd of october the matter of
business closures during lockdown was
considered for inclusion in the policy
legal advice was that there is specific
legislation
covering these matters breach of which
may be
relevant to trigger a review of a
premises license
but this does not need to be
specifically mentioned in the policy
the committee voted unanimously to
recommend to full council
that it be adopted without further
amendment
that concludes my summary and if there
are any questions i'll do my best to
answer
or refer them to the licensing officer k
sanders who led the review
and i would like to personally like to
thank the licensing team which is a
small team and this was an enormous
amount of work
so i would like to thank them for that
thank you that concludes my report
counselor guthrie thank you and your
thanks have been recorded
can we have a second to please
yes i'm happy to second thee
i think it's the recommendation on page
33 that
councillor norris was hopefully
seconding
yeah so council and lawrence can you
confirm that please
yes indeed i am thank you thank you so
we do have a proposal in a second there
i will now move to questions counselors
may ask as many questions they wish
however they must be relevant to the
subject and the discussion
and must be a question so i don't want a
whole
sentence beforehand let's stick to the
questions and you'll get a prompt answer
i'm sure
so the first person we have is counselor
otton please
uh thank you chairman it's not a
question but it is just a statement that
i'm pleased to see within the report
um can i carry on
uh no we'll leave that to debate so
i get where you're going but it's not a
question so are there any questions
please
okay moving on then um
we'll now move to debate councillors
will be allowed to speak once
for three minutes and it will be timed
council rotten
uh yes um i've noted on page sixty and i
believe there was another page
the statement of f um stairs the
evidence of the right to work in the
uk must be provided just to say i'm
pleased to see that because it then
demonstrates the council's commitment um
to the anti-slavery project
thank you very much what a very
important point
are there any other people that wish to
debate this
no okay um council guthrie do you wish
to add anything
no not at all thank you very much thank
you i'm going to read out that proposal
again just so everybody's fresh before
we go to the vote
it's the proposal or the recommendation
3.1
that the draft revision the draft
revision
licensing act 2003 statement of
licensing policy document as attached
at annex a to this report be adopted for
publication
and to take effect for five years unless
sooner revised
from the 7th of january 2021.
and i asked the court uh asked the
corporate manager governance and civic
office
to conduct the electronic votes thank
you chair
councillors can you please open the vote
in the modern.gov app
by clicking the plus sign in the top
right hand of the
agenda screen and selecting attendance
and voting
in the voting tab the vote for this
agenda will show in blue
please click on that thin blue line to
open the vote thank you
thank you councillors that was the unit
unanimously voted for
thank you thank you that is carried
moving now onto mc2014 ic strategy
i'd like to invite uh councillor morley
to introduce the ict
strategy which is for comment only
councillor molly please
thank you chair to get where we are now
we've spent the last 18 months or so
undergoing some restructuring
we've restructured ict following the
review of the ict provision instigated
by our assistant director for customers
digital transformation and improvement
sarah wilcox we have brought in a new
corporate manager for ict
matt harding and restructured the whole
team
bringing them back from suffolk county
council
and back under our own offices direct
management
we have strengthened relationships with
suffolk county councils it
to make sure that we get the best value
from the partnership and that we
continue to develop our ict provision
a natural progression then was to build
a new ict strategy
based on these new foundations
so to the strategy the focus of our ict
strategy
like our other key strategies is about
ensuring
ultimately that ict can enable better
outcomes for our residents
and businesses and staff can fulfill
their roles effectively and efficiently
so this strategy seeks to unlock value
in our existing partnership with suffolk
county
council and our existing software estate
the building blocks of this strategy are
informed by people process and data
as just one local example think of the
power
of the suffolk corona watch pages online
and now imagine that type of data
dashboard applied
for example to our housing stock or to
our climate change and biodiversity
ambitions this strategy paves the way
by helping to ensure that our data is
captured and is accurate and meaningful
i would also like to take this
opportunity to not just thank our own
ict department
but also the ict team at suffolk county
council
without both teams working in
partnership a lot of what we are able to
do today
including this meeting and the live
streaming of it would simply not be
possible
so i'm going to hand over to matt
harding who will present a high level
summary of the ict strategy and then
after mata's finished his presentation
he will then hand back to the chair who
will open up the session for comments
thank you councilman thank you before we
go on with the presentation uh
councillor passport see your hands up is
this a point of order
now i'll leave it to questions at the
end thank you thank you thank you very
much
okay um in that case i'd like to welcome
the corporate manager for ict matt
um matt harding please begin your
presentation
when you're ready thank you thank you
chair thank you councillor morley uh
i am going to share my screen with you
briefly so just give me two seconds
let me know if you can't see
my screen with the big words ict
strategy written on them
okay so very quickly i want to take you
through a very high level
uh overview of the ict strategy you've
got the papers there if you
if you want more detail but we thought
it would be
beneficial today to make sure we did
that so
very quick overview then we'll come back
for comments
uh in terms of rit strategy it is built
around four key principles
those of people process data
and technology you will have undoubtedly
heard the phrase people process and
technology
in terms of being the three key areas
from an it perspective
that help to keep an organization
efficient and ready to take full
advantage of transformation
opportunities
to me another way of looking at these
areas is to look at them as key
principles in the successful delivery of
it
if we don't involve people or support
them
look at their processes and understand
them we're not going to implement
technology
that works for them people and process
both create
and are also informed by data data is
one of our potentially most overlooked
assets
and an asset that it can help to surface
to provide the additional insights and
support and support
and support that services and people
need but also
to provide evidence to the organization
of both the need for and the results of
change and with that in mind that's why
we stuck
with the people process data technology
principles for our key strategy
as our key principles that just to give
a little bit more detail on those
um from a people perspective it's about
connecting the staff of baba and mid
suffolk with the information
and insight that enables them to
undertake their roles effectively
from wherever they may be it's also
about connecting
our residents and our customers to the
services that we provide them in the
most cost-effective and efficient way
enabling them to self-serve digitally
where appropriate but not forgetting
that not everyone can
or will self-serve digitally or has the
ability to
do so it's also ensuring that we as
an organization are unable to
collaborate across the organization
and across our partners and delivery
agency other delivery agencies to make
sure that we connect key strands of work
quickly and effectively finally on the
people side it's also about ensuring our
communication tools
that we that we use are modern and fit
for purpose
and that the communications that we make
with both customers and partners of
baylor and suffolk
is relevant timely accurate and is
through relevant mediums and channels
process is about making sure we assess
our technologies
to to understand and make sure that they
are enablers
of effective processes within our
organization
and where possible automating those
processes where it makes sense to do so
and leveraging technologies that help to
digitally enable processes within baber
and mid-suffolk
i want to be able to automate those
repetitive robotic tasks
that free up staff time to enable them
to focus on more meaningful
and where a process can't be automated
end-to-end or it doesn't actually make
sense to do so
we should look to accelerate those parts
of the process where it does make sense
to do so
and can be done to ensure that residents
still get better services
albeit in
thank you for your patience uh we lost
the external link to the
to the rest of the world so our live
link went down with the uh with the um
with the youtube side uh i can confirm
though that while we're off there i
obviously stopped the meeting
at the point that we lost that link and
while we've been off air we've discussed
no
business of the council at all so we'll
now go back to the presentation
and matt i'd like to go back two slides
please just in case people have missed
two slides and i'd also like to welcome
councillor pratt to the meeting
matt okay
thank you chair um right just going back
two
sets of animation on the one slide so
hopefully
there will be if there is repetition it
will be brief um
in terms of the process element or a
process principle
we want to make sure that from a process
perspective we assess our technologies
with the view to ensuring that they are
enablers to effective processes within
the organization and where possible and
where
it makes sense to do so automate those
processes
oh i'm not sure sorry hang on i've just
realized i'm not sharing my slide
that's my fault
okay
try again right i did talk about
minimizing repetition and i failed
spectacularly there we go right
so process
we want to ensure that we assess our
technologies with a view to ensuring
their enablers to effective processes
within the organization
and where possible automate those
processes processes where it makes
sense to do so specifically those that
help to enable
digital end-to-end processes within
babur mid-suffolk
we also want to automate those
repetitive robotic tasks
that allow us to free up our staff to
focus on more meaningful
activities where a process can't be
automated
end-to-end or it doesn't make sense to
do so we want to look to accelerate
those
accelerate those parts of this process
where it does make sense to do so and it
can be done
so that we continue to ensure that our
residents still get better services
albeit incrementally better
from a data perspective we want to make
sure that we utilize technology to
surface the data we hold
to make it integral to the day-to-day
running of our business
we want to integrate those data sets
that help us to make informed
evidence-based decisions
that improve those services and products
and where possible we want to take up
the appropriate
opportunities that data provides us both
internally held data
and externally provided data to provide
insight into the potential future demand
for existing and new services
we have to be mindful though that this
is about doing anything with data we
have to do safely and securely
after all the data we hold isn't ours
but is that
of our resident and as such they expect
that we are safe stewards of it
lastly technology we want to make sure
that we build accuracy into the running
of rit services
enabling proactive understanding of the
financial people and asset implications
of our technology services
but making sure we only exploit
appropriate new technologies
whilst leveraging our existing
technology stat so
so that we can support the ambitions of
baby and mid-suffolk
and improve outcomes for our customers
i want to be able to come back to you at
some point in the future and make sure
that we have delivered an i.t service
that is aligned to the needs of the
services and staff of baby mid-suffolk
ensuring it staff are engaged early and
often by services
in their continuous improvement
i'd like to just briefly go on to how
this sort of fits with our architecture
and i will be repeating some of the
words that
counselor morley used at the beginning
but i just want to show how this works
so to all intents and purposes as
councillor morley said
one of the things i want to make sure is
that our our data
in our it is there specifically to
provide better outcomes for our
residents and customers
that's all intents and purposes in its
simplistic form
means that we need better products and
services those products and services
that meet our residents needs
and from an architecture perspective we
tend to think about this in an i.t
world in sort of three layers our front
office i.e
the area where users sorry users
residents interact with us whether that
be through to left telephone whether
that be through online
our middle office where potentially we
take data or information provided
to the front office by our residents and
then implement it and push it into our
back office which is our line of
business systems
if we get our front office right we can
start thinking about
how we increase our customer engagement
how we increase self-service
opportunities
by making sure we do end-to-end
digitization of process
if we get our middle office right we can
start thinking about
actually automating the provision of
that data from front office
straight into back office systems again
that provides better services
it increases our data quality because
quite frankly and
no no disrespect to us as human beings
we mistype things
but making that flow easier means we can
put mandatory stuff in place and it
reduces the effort
that staff need to do in that manual
intervention work
allowing allowing them again to
undertake
more meaningful tasks work potentially
closer to the customer
and if we get our line of business
systems right in the back office
we can make sure we have stuff and
systems that are easy to use
that are fit for purpose modern
accessible from anywhere
but most importantly we start to
understand individual service costs
for individual residents all of this
provides us with data
which we can start to interrogate in a
different way
by having that data we can provide
something called descriptive analytics
to all intents and purposes
what is happening now those real-time
dashboards describing what is happenings
now
can be done in a way that is automated
again reducing staff time in data
provisioning and manipulation
ultimately if we start to think about
external data sources and bringing those
in as well we can move towards
predictive analytics
i.e what is going to happen those two
things
descriptive and predictive allow us to
start to better design and commission
services and products
that are evidence-based and demand
predicted
in a nutshell that is what we want our
strategy to do
and i thank you for your time i
apologize for the repetition
but i'll hand back over now to susie
before to take comments
thank you matt for your presentation and
we do look forward to having you back at
some future point
for a progress report i'm sure we'll all
be very interested in that
counselor morley before we go with you
are there any questions or comments
please i can see initially we'll go for
councillor passmore
followed by councillor penyong um
thank you very much chairman justin
comments um very very interesting and uh
just take this opportunity and say well
done to the it department during covert
for all you've done
i think it's been an incredible
achievement and i really do mean that
you have
enabled us to carry on um come hell or
high water so i think that's a real
gold star for everybody involved so
please i'm sure i speak for everybody
saying that
and i think this is really really
important just a couple of comments
suggestions
um when we get it and this is at a high
level
i'm merely an agriculturalist so i don't
understand any of this technical stuff
but there's a serious point here
actually matthew it's about making it
easy to use
and understand without too much
technical stuff that um as you probably
know i would get lost in
particularly if we're looking to
residents and businesses and so on out
there
one of the issues we need to work very
hard at and there's a government
responsibilities with colleagues in the
county council of course
is connectivity the broadband um
wi-fi um 5g that's the world i was
looking for see i told you i didn't know
much about it
those are really really important
factors and they could i suppose
if you probably revolutionize it one of
the things i think is really crucial
the data that you use and harvest and
use as evidence in order to decide what
we do how we allocate resources and
investments on
i can't emphasize that enough based on
evidence you can talk to the public
and so on this is why we're doing it
could i also make a plea if we can use
technology in time to make sure we're
doing everything possible
particularly in remote rural areas we've
got issues of isolation
you look at the community foundation
hidden needs reports a lot of stuff in
there that is
really worth using but also to preserve
those who are perhaps reaching the
sunset of their life or perhaps are
um very finding it very challenging with
their younger old
to live independently how will we use
that
and then the last comment i really want
to make
linking in with other public services
and the voluntary sector
and in the voluntary sector include our
parish councils i think all of us find
most parish council meetings done for
example using zoom
will will be able to help facilitate
that doesn't matter to me i can use it
on my um
desktop at home as i suspect many of us
are so what are the other mediums we can
use within this strategy
um to make it ease of access
communication
and that those sorts of things are
really really important but we mustn't
forget the voltage sector
and related to that i'm thinking of
other issues
on a socio-economic basis of for example
if someone's been a victim of domestic
abuse and has to move
looking at the housing keeping them safe
and providing making us deliver our
services better
so those are only comments i just wanted
to share them with with you and
everybody else because i think it's a
real opportunity which i'm sure
we will all want to grasp with vigor so
thank you very much
yeah very good points um
please thank you chairman um
i have to say that uh councillor
passmores probably
stolen pretty much a lot of my thunder
and most of everybody else's with his
long commentary
but nevertheless i think he does touch
on a very important
aspect of this digital strategy
and having been a counselor for about
six years now i'm i'm
absolutely delighted with the progress
we've made on this front because i think
it's absolutely vital to the way that
the council will function
going into the into the future and the
way that we communicate and
exchange information and ideas within
our communities
but obviously underpinning all of that
is a robust
broadband network and i think this is
something that you know we as
councillors
across all of the different levels of
government
need to really press for because not
only will it help with the social
isolation but i think it's also
absolutely vital for growing the economy
of our district
so those are the comments i would like
to make
um taking on board all of the things
that countless possible with his lack of
i.t knowledge has managed to say in the
meantime thank you very much
councillor ekpanyong thank you moving on
now to councillor whitehead please
followed by councillor mansell
oh thank you chairman our people are
quite clearly at the heart of this
strategy
it's so important that our staff have
access to the appropriate technology
that is both joined up and aligned i
think a great recent example that
springs to mind is
our building services team we invest in
tablet devices which are managed and
regularly updated
so they could remotely access microsoft
teams which is a key communication
tool allowing them to participate in
online team meetings
training and well-being events indeed
when we first entered
lockdown throughout the organization we
were able to rapidly move to new ways of
accessing our it
we had rigor around our ict asset
register and could clearly see which
staff members
had which laptop or pc i think without
such rigor we would clearly have been in
a very different place
so i'm so pleased to see the importance
of accuracy and data
referenced throughout this strategy
thank you
thank you councillor mansell please
uh thank you chair um uh first of all
i'd just like to make a point
that um there's no mention of members
in the document that we had attached to
our council agenda
it talks about staff and customers
but my main point that i wanted to make
is to do with the
cloud-based solutions which are
described on page 74
and it talks about looking at the cost
and security concerns
and i would just like to know whether as
well as those concerns um
whether we are also looking at the
carbon footprint of the data centers and
the cloud-based solutions that we're
using
and uh whether that is being taken into
consideration
in our pledge to become carbon neutral
by 2030
oops sorry i think that's deserved an
answer so
either matthew please or counselor molly
i think i'll hand over to matthew that's
okay
yes please matthew i can say something
as well if you like
uh we'll go to matthew first thank you
thank you councillor mansell in terms of
that cost yes exactly one of the things
we will be looking at is the green cost
i can you know one of our key vendors
today microsoft
this year alone and have announced that
they will themselves be carbon negative
by 2030 obviously contributing quite a
lot because we
are key microsoft users in fact a number
of our vendors including
firms like capita use microsoft's cloud
services
such as the azure data centers which
will also therefore be carbon negative
by 2030
wide data centers in terms of cloud
technology allows us to actually make
an improvement around our greenhouse gas
emissions whether that be from
dematerialization
and they're not the less need for firm
kit or tin
as we would call it in the it industry
those bits of device that we all use
and efficiencies through being able to
share services
the energy and the air conditioning
needs rather than having data centers
out the back of buildings
thank you thank you and council man so i
think your point about
members is not lost on either councilor
morley or matthew and that will be
corrected for the future
thank you moving on now to councillor
geek please
thank you chair um i was really glad to
hear the word residence in many places
in the presentation but the actual i.t
strategy document
often uses the word customers as a
synonym
the district council does of course have
customers but these aren't the same as
residents
residents are the citizens of
mid-southwest and the difference between
a customer and a citizen
is that a customer has a kind of
transactional relationship with the
council
with no wider responsibility to other
customers or to the community
but residents do have individual
responsibilities to the rest of the
community as
citizens now i know this is a small
point but i do feel strongly that we
should encourage an awareness of our
individual responsibilities
with appropriate language in all our
policies and strategies
thank you thank you council geeker
it's not small matter actually i think i
think your point is extremely valid and
i'm
hoping that matthew take that take that
away
thank you okay moving now to councillor
phil please
thank you chair yes just a brief comment
i think
clearly we need an i.t strategy and it's
good to see us moving in a modern
direction
i just say i don't think there's
anything that appears to be
controversial in this statement of the
direction of travel
it tends to be rather motherhood an
apple pie
but a better use of data which was
emphasized is a clearly a good direction
of travel
if we could get to the point where
people use the model features of modern
applications it would be a great start
i i see few use of the ability for
instance to insert revisions or
for instance or online cooperation
between people
during the production of documents um
anything that gets us to the point where
there's less need to the frequent
comment
if the technology works would be
absolutely wonderful
uh in our quest for a movement forward
we must be sure that our applications
are sufficiently reliable
and that people are sufficiently trained
to be comfortable doing tasks digitally
i think i want to emphasize that last
point you know
that the technology exists uh on a
worldwide basis
it's really they're making sure that our
staff are well trained and perhaps we as
councillors
also don't struggle with simple things
like unmuting ourselves for
uh during meetings it would be
great and would generate a a
significant leap forward certainly less
annoyance
when you're participating thank you
i was going to just play around there
and not not mute myself but it's a very
valid point
because i'm guilty of that as much as
anyone training is is paramount without
shell of a doubt
okay moving on to councillor fleming
followed by councillor richardson please
yes thank you thank you very much and um
it might surprise you to know that i am
happy to support this strategy
i'm not always the biggest fan of i.t
because i believe it will greatly
strengthen
our capacity to manage and most
importantly to store
our data and to tailor our approach to
how we use it to our own needs
and i like the ending statement in the
strategy keep it simple
well let's try and do that if we can
this strategy is particularly important
for our public realm and environment
teams
as they undertake their work
successfully given
our commitments to climate change and
biodiversity
for example we we will need to manage
and sort the data again from our
ecological ecological mapping program
and integrate this with other sets of
data
that are available on the environment in
various forms
including old data and hard copy which
will need to be integrated
and form a unit with what we've got and
in response to
councillor mansell's um excellent
question
on cloud storage which is potentially
carbon intensive as
i think most of us know due to the need
for cooling but
our carbon accounting systems will take
into account
all types of emissions including those
associated with indirect
and offshore activities
we will be able to share the information
accurately and quickly
with others who will benefit from it
such as planning team
um like other local authorities or other
interested parties who may come to us
for information and for us to access
external information in the same way
this capacity for data management is
also
important to enable us to make use of
our
emerging health and well-being program
and to our largely
rural economy it enables us to share
information
effectively with and on behalf of our
residents
knowing that it ultimately belongs to
them i.e you
thank you
thank you council fleming um we'll now
go to council richardson
followed by councillor brewster please
councillor richardson
thank you very much chair um there's a
few points um i'd like to make if i may
um the first is that i think this is a
really welcome opportunity
for us to use our ict strategy to
improve the services that we provide
to our residents and customers because i
think they're both perfectly valid and
useful terms
i think the way that we can do that is
by making the services we provide more
interactive more efficient more
user-friendly
to enable more of our residents and
customers to be able to interact
um and engage with um in southern
district council and the services we
provide
particularly as i think counselors have
already said
um those members of our community who
may be isolated or suffering from
loneliness i think that's a really
important way that we can keep in touch
um with those individuals and help them
and support their needs
the other point which um i would like to
make is just the actual impact it can
have
on the um the council itself both staff
and members
because i think one of the great um kind
of reflections that i've had
um certainly over the last few months is
that and this is not just based on my
own experience but what i've sort of
heard anecdotally from others
is that this shift towards more remote
more homework more flexible working
actually has significant qualitative
benefits
um for people in the workforce so i
think um
that will be that is a benefit that i
think our
all of our officers can can enjoy going
forward and i hope that's something
that degree of flexibility is something
we can retain in the future
and just speaking personally um i'm a
counselor who also works full-time so
can sometimes find it a little bit
tricky to
to juggle all of my various commitments
and i have to say that
um having a lot of not just these full
me full council meetings
because obviously i appreciate these uh
these are meetings which would be much
better done in person but actually all
of these other committee meetings
briefings that can be done virtually
done online
um that for me makes um local government
much more accessible
for someone who is younger and obviously
in full-time employment
um but there's two other points i'd like
to make here which is um
well indirectly i think this this um
particular strategy will have an impact
both on climate change um and our
biodiversity strategy
um because one um way that obviously
by virtue of the fact that we have been
able to meet um virtually rather than in
person
is we can reduce um the impact on
climate change by reducing the amount
of time we spend traveling and commuting
we can do much more remotely
and therefore reduce our carbon
footprint as a result and i know ask you
matthew talked about microsoft as one of
our major software vendors but actually
what i found particularly interesting
was that they are also trialling
an online calculator that will tell you
your usage
of their produce in terms of co2
emissions so i think that's actually a
really welcome aspect that we can
we can definitely draw upon um and then
the other aspect is around
our obviously our biodiversity action
plan um because i think it's it's really
important
to understand um the usage of data
um in undertaking some of the
geographical mapping work that we've
done for
things like um tree planting um i think
data is really key
um not just in terms of the the
specifics of the biodiversity
um action plan but also more broadly
things like um planning so that um
planning um staff and planning decisions
can be made
uh and taken with a more holistic
approach um so imagine that could be
something from
using third-party data around noise or
air pollution
um or or anything else that can can
contribute to that aspect of our
of our strategic priorities so i think
this is a really important
um report that we've been given and a
really important strategy
not only in and of itself but because of
the ways it contributes to various other
aspects of
of our work so i would really welcome
this um thank you chair
thank you uh now moving on to councillor
brewster followed by council of war boys
councillor brewster please
thank you chair um yeah i just would
like to say this
this ict strategy has helped us respond
to the challenges that we've faced as a
result of the coronavirus pandemic
the use of collaborative tools like
microsoft teams
microsoft forms and cloud-based services
have helped the councils to
continue to deliver existing and new
services
we're using music ms teams to hold this
meeting
and we have used technology to automate
repetitive tasks
to free up staff time so they can focus
more time and effort on code response
we also used existing tools to rapidly
implement
new online forms that supported people
to apply for new business grants and
that was uh a lot of work went into that
and a lot of work went into paying those
business grants as well
and still is as a result
the core of our strategy has stood the
test of covert
and whilst we may have to change
priorities around a little
as a result the strategic outcome
remains the same
that of using the appropriate
technologies to connect our people and
residents
enabling them to do their jobs or
transact with us more efficiently
and use data to provide the evidence of
required service change
and the results of it thank you chair
thank you and council of war boys please
yeah yes i thank you for
the presentation and the work on the the
ict
i think i think it is important that we
embrace
the new technologies and certainly agree
the paradigm of work is changing
um i think that i've got two concerns
really one is um
about the security of the systems i mean
from the point of view of ensuring that
um
our residents are confident that the
data is
secure uh and that our systems are
secure
so that um
from i will say this from from hacking
whether it's malicious or accidental or
simply
a power line going down
we we will become more dependent
i think the effect of the ict and covid
i know the way we've been able to
respond and being supported it has been
tremendous
but uh it has shown our vulnerability in
a way we are vulnerable to power outages
and and data reception and
broadband speeds and things um
and my second point was i think
i it is to do with the tin the hardware
i mean
many of our customers in particular the
ones who are vulnerable and who are most
in need of this connectivity
actually find it difficult to access it
either from a cost
point of view or from uh
developing the the requisite skills so
that is my second concern
we have got to be sort of reaching out
into our communities
to make sure um that
we do have equal access
i think i'm not going to say anymore
no it is i was get i couldn't find a
mute but to a mute
sorry for the delay but we're there now
um councilor morley do you have anything
else to add um yes just a couple of
things
some really powerful
comments and thoughts being expressed
tonight around this
um i don't want anybody for a moment to
think
that this is instead of a friendly face
on the end of a telephone but
the point about automating so much of
our
existing processes is to allow our staff
to free up time so that they can still
talk actually
engage and talk to people who can't
serve themselves
we need to be uh allowing those of us
who can
who are very happy and comfortable using
whatever piece of i.t
kit is thrown at us to to serve
ourselves
so that our officers can spend more time
dealing
with people who are more vulnerable
and covid over the last
eight months or so has
has resulted in a lot of people who've
never in their life used a computer
before
all of a sudden are face timing with
grandkids
as a means of keeping in touch so i
think
it is a great enabler and
at the moment if sometimes it's felt as
somebody who comes from the i.t industry
it's sometimes
felt that we're using
19th century institutions
and 20th century technology in order to
try and solve 21st century problems and
issues
the world doesn't stop or stand still
just because
one of us doesn't have a computer we
need to be utilizing it
freeing up our staff to actually deal
with real people
and real problems and so thank you
everybody for engaging
and discussing this and
look forward to the next stage and thank
you very much matthew
thank you and uh thank you matthew for
an excellent presentation we do look
forward to seeing you again in the
future for an update uh as the way we're
going along
and councillor morley thank you the
report was for comment only
before we move on to councillor
appointments i noticed that we've got uh
councillor pratt has joined the meeting
and uh councillor amirosen is also
during the meeting so welcome
you may now vote on the next uh on the
next agenda point which is counselor
appointments
i believe it might have to be done
verbally but we'll cover that as we go
along
so moving on to council appointments the
change of appointments are listed on the
agenda
are there any others
thank you please could i have a proposal
thank you chair i would like to propose
the two changes thank you
thanks molly thank you and uh a second
to please
uh i'm very happy to second chairman
council brewster thank you i'll now ask
the corporate manager governance and
civic office to conduct the electronic
votes
thank you chair councillors could you
please open the vote in the modern.gov
app by clicking the plus sign in the top
right hand
of the agenda screen and selecting
attendance and voting
in the voting tab the vote for this
agenda item will show in blue
please click on the thin blue line to
open the vote thank you
okay so we have received votes from um
all councillors apart from councillor
amoroson so councillor amoroson would
you like to indicate how you wish to
vote please
four thank you
thank you chair thank you that's um
30 votes four and two abstentions thank
you
that is carried thank you um the date of
the next meeting is thursday the 21st
january 2021 at 5 30 p.m
uh before i close the meeting um i've
obviously started watching christmas
carols and uh and sort of films and
all that stuff in the afternoon and it's
never too early apparently and it's
never too early to say
merry christmas so merry christmas to
you all i hope you have a wonderful
christmas and a safe christmas
and importantly that we all have a
healthy vibrant new year
so i look forward to seeing you next
year thank you for everything you've
done this year
and that you're continuing to do until
the end of the year with that i close
the meeting
you